lisa you've represented many genuine
victims in the in the me too movement
who've won
uh actions and one court case you've
done some amazing work for women who
deserved to have a vindication in
courtrooms how damaging though is it
when someone like amber heard so high
profile
is basically um concluded by a jury
to be a massive liar and they've awarded
15 million dollars against her
it's very damaging and it's very scary
to women who want to speak out many of
them speak out and they don't name their
abuser and in fact she didn't in the
underlying article but you know appears
this is not the end because there will
certainly be appeals i've done
defamation cases and appeals i
represented janice dickinson against
bill cosby in a defamation case we won
two important appeals that's where these
cases are decided and i think this is an
inconsistent verdict because the jury
did award her two million dollars on her
counter claim based on the attorney adam
waldman making statements against her
and that was attributed to johnny depp
so how is it then a false statement if
she says i am a representative of
domestic violence i think that is an
inconsistent verdict and that is not
allowed
so i think there's a lot of issues on
appeal here and the appellate courts are
going to sort it out of course that's
going to take years uh for now you know
he is definitely the big winner today
lisa do you think johnny depp has a
comeback here hollywood loves a comeback
as sharon osbourne said you know he's
been in his eyes he'll say i've been
completely vindicated i took this action
to clear my name and unlike prince
andrew who you know paid a large amount
of money not to clear his name johnny
depp has taken this big gamble which it
was with everything hanging on it really
and he's won um do you think he's got a
chance now to come back to
to be a big hollywood star again
absolutely because hollywood not only
loves a comeback it loves wealthy
powerful a-list celebrities and it's
very hard to go up against them you know
i do it every day on behalf of everyday
people it's always a david and goliath
struggle and i i think he will
definitely have a comeback one of the
complaints that people had about aspects
of the metoo movement
was that the pendulum swung very wildly
and may have swung too far in the sense
that this concept you have to believe
all women
you know one of the things that people
will say about this trial i'm sure this
case is that well why if someone like
amber heard is lying to destroy
uh
her ex-husband johnny depp why should
the automatic de facto default position
always be you must believe women
well of course we should not believe all
women or all men but and everybody
should have due process but i every day
talk to my clients and they are suicidal
they are upset they have corroborative
evidence and even so it is a huge uphill
battle to go against somebody who is
very wealthy who can have social media
bots coming after you private
investigators going through your garbage
and talking to your family members i
mean these cases are very hard in my
opinion the metoo movement has not gone
far enough we are definitely seeing a
backlash now i think this case is a good
example every case should be decided on
its own merits based on the facts of
course nobody should be falsely accused
but there are still many many women out
there who are victims of sexual
harassment and sexual assault
well thank you lisa as always a great
analysis really appreciate you joining
us tonight on what has been a pretty
momentous day certainly in terms of the
fortunes of the people involved here
joined by uh tommy lehrer from fox
nation and also janice dickinson i spoke
to uh last week about this case welcome
to both of you uh tommy lehrer and uh
what do you make of it
hey listen i think that this is also a
big victory in the battle against cancel
culture
and in america we've dealt with that for
two plus years now listen i would have
had respect for amber hurd if she would
have penned an op-ed talking about how
toxic relationships can be so damaging
and talking about getting yourself out
of a toxic situation i would have had
respect for her if she had gone that
route she didn't she wanted to cancel
johnny depp the world watched her try to
cancel johnny depp and in the end of the
day she lost and i believe it was a
rightful loss and going back to this
whole notion of the me too movement it
is maybe started with wonderful
intentions but as you mentioned peers it
has gone far too far we can't just
believe all women because believe it or
not women can be abusers too and i
believe that's what amber heard was tell
me let me just she believes amber heard
was and now she's gonna have to pay for
it right let me just read you there's a
statement here from amber uh her which
i'm gonna read in full and get your
reaction to it the disappointment i feel
today she says is beyond words i'm
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still wasn't enough to stand up
to disproportionate power influence and
sway my ex-husband i'm even more
disappointed with what this verdict
means for other women it's a setback it
sets back the clock to a time when a
woman who spoke up and spoke up could be
publicly shamed and humiliated it sets
back the idea that violence against
women is to be taken seriously i believe
johnny's attorney succeeded in getting
the jury to overlook the key issue of
freedom of speech and ignore evidence
that was so conclusive that we won in
the uk i'm sad i lost this case but i'm
sadder still but i seem to have lost a
right i thought as an american to speak
freely and openly now tommy larry i
would say no one's damaged her free
speech she was allowed to speak freely
and openly but the jury concluded that
what she was saying was a lie
and not just a lie but a deliberate
malicious lie designed to destroy her
husband and that's why they found
against her and that's why they've
awarded him so much money
yeah free speech doesn't mean that you
could lie about somebody else for your
own personal gain or to bolster your own
career in hollywood and what have you
and when she's talking about a setback
she is the setback for women when you
have somebody in her position with such
a platform that she has and the jury
finds that you lied about it with actual
malice you are the setback to so many
women that don't have the platform that
you have that have actually been abused
and don't have a voice she should be
ashamed of herself and we'll see if she
can make a comeback but i don't think so
you can't go after people you can't
cancel them for no reason this is a big
victory for johnny depp and the war
against cancel culture let me bring in
uh janice dickinson janice we spoke
about this uh last week and you know you
were i think hopeful this would be the
verdict are you what do you think johnny
depp's reaction would have been to this
i think johnny depp is absolutely
relieved for for the fact that you know
after all these several weeks and months
that this trial's been going on that
he's been hammered with all these
accusations and all these defamatory
remarks coming from his ex-wife amber
heard
i think you know i think he's he's going
to going through uh
he's going to have relief because i was
once in the
the defamatory case with bill cosby
and uh you know we found
him to be liable
and so i was vindicated and my
vindication feelings were just utter
relief well actually we've got a there's
a statement now from johnny depp i think
he said something along the lines of the
jury the jury gave me my life back i am
truly humbled and i don't think he's
overstating that because i think had he
lost this case johnny depp would have
been finished so mistakes were
unbelievably high for him
absolutely pierce you know he you know
it begins to slide down once once a
celebrity is accused of something the
telephone stopped ringing for future
jobs it happened to me and it was like
really heartbreaking and i'm sure he got
cancelled from the pirates of the
caribbean franchise and he got cancelled
from all these other jobs and this is
millions of dollars for this poor guy
poor guy
uh you know i think that um
i think he's good has a big sense of
relief now and and the the public the
court of public opinion for him is that
i was right when i came on your show
last week and i said i'm pro johnny depp
because i don't believe amber heard i
never believed i never believed all her
accusations from the start it sounded
like a pathetic woman
just clamoring for attention to make
herself i mean what does she gain from
doing this in the first place i also
think i have to say i also think that
when you lose so emphatically continuing
to play
the wallowing victim i think it leaves a
pretty unpleasant taste in the mouth uh
tommy and janice thank you both very
much really appreciate that